the fundamental assumptions of Western
civilization are valid how about that
you know it's not you think it's an
accident
oh here's how you find out okay which
countries do people want to move away
from hey not ours which countries do
people want to move to ours guess what
they work better and it's not because we
went around the world stealing
everything we could get our hands on
it's because we got certain fundamental
assumptions right thank God for that
after thousands and thousands of years
of trying and because of that we've
managed to establish a set of
civilizations that are shining lights in
the world you know now you can be pretty
damn filthy and still be a shining light
in this world right because if you look
around the world at the state of
governance in most places it's like the
most pathological corrupt and vicious
thugs rule and to stand out as an
illuminated light against that
background is it so difficult but
nonetheless you know we're as good as
it's got and unless we can come up with
something better we should be very
careful about messing around with that
so why don't we start with the
assumption that we're doing something
right one of the things we're doing
right for example is that we actually
value the individual right the
individual has intrinsic value in
Western societies you know how long it
took people to formulate that as an idea
and how unlikely that idea is that poor
you you know useless powerless you with
all your damn fault you're actually
worth something you're worth something
to the point that the law has to respect
you god we don't want to abandon that
for some half-witted collectivism which
we're doing as rapidly as possible
because one of the things that
characterizes the radical left types is
they don't give a damn about you as an
individual or about individuals at all
you're black or you're white or you're
Latino or you're transsexual you're
homosexual or whatever you're a group
you're a member of a group and the only
thing that matters is the group well I
can tell you if the only thing that
matters is the group you bloody well
don't matter very much and then you got
to ask yourself just exactly what sort
of people are trying to set things up so
it is that
the individual doesn't matter very much
well it's the sort of people to whom the
individual doesn't matter very much and
I might suggest that you don't elect
them and that when they attempt to take
power that you do everything you can to
stalk them
[Applause]